here we are here we are h3 after dark
forever
unless someone knocks on us and gets us
suspended we are here every friday
i think that's the only after dark we've
missed
in almost a year yeah this is number
48 or 49. almost almost a year into
after darkness why did i feel like we
missed more than that
well i was away
yeah you missed i don't i never miss
how does it feel to be me today ela
elo is running late hey
she's the reason we're late
b she's posting up doing a post at the
last minute before we go live and she
goes wow i'm you today i says how does
it feel to be a loser
i personally really hated the experience
and i'm going to go back to my old ways
now you know what it feels like to be me
and so stressful how do you do that
every time
i'm i'm a mess what do you mean
well you know why i started off so late
and it's happening to me a lot is
because every time i walk into my closet
it's like almost everything i'm looking
at is not going to fit me so i don't
know what to wear
sounds like an excuse right
got a vibe struggles
well what'd you pick today let me see is
this maternity pants
no you know what i i'm just not i
haven't unbuttoned my uh
you want to show off your your outfit's
pretty cool you got a vest what are you
going fishing
and since reebok looks sick bro
show it work it work it work it i want
to show you guys only two buttons are
closed
[Applause]
thank you
thank you trevor thank you appreciate
you listen you know we've got a banger
today pretty much like always but oh
hold on
gabe here
gabe with the legendary internet
connection
[ __ ] yeah where are we today oh you're
on a playground okay
playground in the park having my ice
cream baby [ __ ] day [ __ ] baby yeah is
that a little sketchy yeah
[Laughter]
you're on a playground are you with a
child
no child no child in sight baby
you're not offering ice cream to kids or
anything are you
no okay good just making sure yeah
yeah okay good just making sure you know
just had to ask i love the tiny window
we got today yeah
he's really small today too this what's
with this i think it's a bandwidth thing
it's automatically reduced in his eyes
so gabe tell me about uh your friday
baby
tell me about your friday baby my
friends
[Applause]
we love friday what you doing this
weekend
yes we can probably have like um maybe
have
maybe go out have family time and all
that stuff hanging out with your family
and friends hell yeah nice because it's
friday huh do you have work for school
yeah start the weekend
you have to work or school nope
[ __ ] yeah baby
[Music]
gabe was doing one last week
oh yeah
yeah it's kind of like a howl thing
that would work too i like that
it's friday baby
friday baby
[ __ ] yeah
today's for legends baby
fridays for legends
oh yeah love you buddy all right maybe
move up the playground okay
sure
love you bye
thanks for checking in
[Applause]
we're basically watching like a
slideshow of photos
i feel like every week it's
progressively getting worse connection
yeah we're just like
that was probably the worst connection
we've experienced so far [ __ ] baby now
yeah eating ice cream baby now oh yeah
my mom it's friday right mom you want to
join me
baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] it's friday
baby [ __ ] that's my mom ladies and
gentlemen yeah so um
shout out obviously to gabe white club
gabe you can find him on cameo as well
as everybody else in my life
everybody's on camera oh thank you to
our sponsors hellofresh honey and kraken
you know we love these people
give it up that's right
okay some top of the show stuff but yeah
we have first of all if you guys missed
mr verified today's the big results and
i'm gonna be doing a little refresher
and you guys are gonna have time to get
your final votes in but basically we
held a contest for all the guys
on wednesday you can watch the whole
competition on our off the rails but
it's a fantastic episode and the guys
are competing to be mr verified which
means that i will be writing one single
email
to my social rep at twitter instagram
and tick tock to get them verified no
guarantees but so you're
i have to like
say that it's not just writing a single
email it's like you got to choose wisely
when you ask for favors
so you're you're using a favorite credit
absolutely
graciously oh i'm so graciously thanks
for pointing that out
hey you're absolutely right it doesn't
cost me nothing
um so that's coming up
if they want to vote the uh
the link is in the description of the
episode and it's also a pinned in the
chat
okay you know we also have here with us
today you guys have met olivia
she was an intern but she's been
converted to a full-blown employee wow
feels good thank you
so quickly too that took it in like a
year right to me
under the gun
it was this her school and i made the
right choice she listened to gabe she's
like [ __ ] school for the record i don't
like having that on me
i did
but i don't i said i said listen
i'm not going to tell you
to quit school i'm not i don't want you
to quit you know it's a big decision to
make yeah i'll just tell you that
whatever if the opportunity is here for
you if you want it
and um
you know
well i'm very grateful for it and school
it'll always be there so we'll see what
happens really best job in the world
baby
i told
she was a drama major i
mean oh ian you dropped out too i
dropped out too yeah you did yeah wait
did we i never know that loved it too
love wait a bunch of football oh my god
i am corrupted we're destroying
am i the only one with a degree here i
have a degree i have a degree yeah i
have a certain degree yeah i do
but to be honest with you guys just that
like i don't i personally
as a college graduate i don't think that
degrees mean anything like i personally
don't at all
i i welcome both ways yes especially
considering how expensive it is here
it's like a big decision if you want to
go that route and have debt for like 10
years
or you want to go another route well 10
years ago legitimate to choose not to do
it but in my in my
uh opinion work experience is infinitely
more valuable than
and you know from the hp podcast sky's
the limit
very true the best job in the world baby
but it's so good nobody ever leaves but
ironically the h3 podcast exists because
of my degree
because of my
video article that's true that is iran's
origin story that is ironic anyway
olivia welcome
thank you welcome welcome
olivia stand up
stand up stand up stand up olivia
how long did you work for us like a
month or something or maybe more
months
but she was such an asset that um
i didn't want to let her go
you know i offered a job and she took it
so i did not want to go thank you thank
you
so much what a guy so now that we're at
the top of the show
before we get too deep into everything i
want to refresh everybody on the mr
verified and then urge everyone to go
cast their vote and at the bottom of the
show we're going to announce the big
winner this is big guys i don't want to
i don't want to understate what a big
moment this is
um
ela actually hasn't seen it um
no i started watching the episode but
have not um
made it too far because i also challenge
fall asleep every evening now yeah and
well yeah if ella's not watching how can
i expect anyone else to i'm just kidding
i don't care but you guys should go
watch mr verified so here is a little
bit of a refresher this is ian
talent portion uh first up we have young
ian that's it's a play on uh miss
america
universe i am not going to waste too
much time and i will let you symbol of
me like so this is
within 90 seconds so we're gonna on the
clock hey guys
kim kardashian send me this collector
guys let's see what she sent today
oh it's so earthy oh i mean in body fuel
birthday cake bash with cream
and then the i think the real doom for
you tummy tea this is like a laxative
when you guys go he started chugging
laxatives and then he actually puked
twice
that was the real booty right ian
uh it's like a it's a brand of it's the
same thing yeah you know they have this
this uh flat belly tea and it just makes
you [ __ ] yes you knew that i didn't know
that but it seems illegal ian weren't
you just feeling sick the whole way oh
yeah
yeah i feel like i just come to work for
like [ __ ] and vomit
piss and he loved that
and you dropped school
for that okay
yeah well yeah well um
you know
we love him he had a great performance
he puked twice
legend [ __ ] yeah legend [ __ ]
uh dan of course did his anti you you
you expect nothing else
then yeah he did an anti uh
application
and basically he did a great kind of
communist manifesto speech about why not
to vote for him
thank you thank you uh riveting the
powers of silicon valley have entered
into an unholy alliance to exercise this
specter
zuckerberg and dorsey
[Music]
where is the poster in opposition that
has not been decried as a troll by their
opponents in power where is the
opposition that has not been hurled back
the branding reproach of troll say what
oh bring him out against the more
advanced
blue check marks yeah so he rallies
against the man and a very derivative
resulting from this fact i said dan what
exactly was the talent he said oration
so oration we love dan which is not a
skill to be um so he's basically asking
not to get it he says do not vote for me
in fact he went a step further he said
if you do vote for me and i do get the
blue checky he promised to post a dong
on instagram to get banned
dong yeah penis i'm going to come and he
was going to tell us
your penis dan or randy no no no no that
would be disgusting how are you going to
how are you going to um
select the penis to post
well if i'm being honest i you know
it won't necessarily be a penis it might
just be something else that will get not
verified like
an isis video or something oh god dan
what the hell
but
you're just trying to get people not to
vote for you
because people were excited about the
dong i prefer that like dan has a pretty
good chance with his strategy though
that's what we were saying is that anti
everybody thinks it's a reverse
psychology thing there was a lot of
comments like that yeah it is
it's not clearly it's not
dad is a great guy
yeah i don't please don't post isis that
will not reflect well on me
i'm like hey can you please verify this
guy starts posting isis videos oh my god
isis uh dub remix
zach of course came out shredding
hard as can be everyone was really
impressed by your shred sack so thank
you round of applause to zach
[Music]
the man can shred ladies and gentlemen
oh
[Music]
yeah
zach ladies and gentlemen awesome yeah
thank you thank you very
much you i feel like you're getting
better and better
yeah um
it was a lot of fun to uh perform that
so i appreciate the opportunity also
zach abandoned our blonde club yes i am
back to uh we're no longer twins
unfortunately now but my hair was
turning not so blonde more but more into
like a piss yellow yeah
i know i was walking around like that
for three months
by the way he was pregnant we ordered
breakfast videos that came late he was
pregnant look who's eating
but we gotta eat them oh my god that's
so good like stop it
what's the name of this place so people
know or should we not say it not say it
keep it to ourselves dude it's so good
abe came out
with a really powerful performance
actually
you guys probably remember his iconic
donkey kong please say if they're really
okay with us eating i feel so bad like i
really do just eat it
i mean what am i gonna do sit here and
let it let it rot for for three hours
basically yes oh no that's that option
a b of course um
you guys remember his donkey kong story
about how
he was playing donkey kong
bungo
jungle beat and uh
really awkward situation here he
reenacts it it was fantastic
look at this this is the game
[Music]
that's good
[Music]
yeah people said they really it made
them uncomfortable if they felt like
they were really there yeah
that was really good
i was actually fascinated to see the
game itself too
and you have to hit it so hard at times
that
he really pulls it up you actually have
to clap for such a little [ __ ]
yeah you have to clap you do
there's like a speaker there
yeah
very impressive i actually came out made
him play it for me too here
and how is that this is just shooting
that [ __ ] out like i did back then
pick it up a notch here maybe
go ahead let's just let's go ahead let's
relive it
[Applause]
okay so what is the clapping they
consent you're clapping yeah
there's a little speaker on it
[Music]
there's a little speaker on i can sense
where i'm clapping and the clap is
usually to get over like an obstacle or
to punch an enemy
okay so interesting so we we drum to
move yep and two drums to jump
to uh both to jump so like right there
yeah yeah yeah these aren't we did also
questions
and um fashion as well so you don't want
to miss the full contest but yes that's
a little that's a little reminder
now is the time for the final votes to
be cast the link is in the description
guys the only one that has access to
that so far is love none of us know
it's
do we have so far love can you see that
how many votes let me see we have 43 000
wow
passionate bunch
do we have a clear winner can you say
that
well
should i say that don't say no no
no i know yeah we do we do have a pretty
clear winner but i do i mean if you guys
vote a lot maybe it can spoil
interesting what happened to your face
love what is that
well we had a fight here in the office
earlier and yeah it wasn't pretty
good for life
you got hit pretty good
yeah it was pretty gnarly all right well
let's get on we got a lot of fun stuff
to get to today
um you know when we filmed that by the
way just a little bit of a
atmospheric i was dying of i had
shawarma diarrhea
and i was just like
okay you show this first and then we
gotta address that
you can't just brush it over
i couldn't even stand man and we were up
so late filming that
i just i couldn't deal with it i just
couldn't stop [ __ ] and it was just
so it was just awesome oh my god
[Music]
this is not this is a candid video i
want to emphasize that that was not
staged at all uh
sniper shots of celebrities
skills
yeah i mean i i slipped
and then you
yeah i know it was crazy it was like
back to that
yeah i slept a little bit on my vegan
diet obviously and i ate a ton of
shawarma
and that maybe wasn't the best way to
break fast
maybe the worst way but it was chicken
shawarma i felt like there was something
funky with that because
oh there's more shawarma videos here's
another one i don't even know what's
here's me
[Laughter]
this is how my aunt used to put us in
timeout exactly like this
what is happening i've just that's how
bad
and i just wanted to push through it
because i really wanted to everyone got
ready right there i was just like man i
can't just go home
the thing is like we didn't start till
four because i couldn't even sit still
for more than five minutes
i think you won a total of like 10 times
wow yeah
gross
zach here's a little tick tock for you
top of the show
someone made a tribute to you have you
seen this uh i have actually oh you have
yeah yeah well
kind of takes the fun out of it okay i
haven't thank you
hello there how you doing
zach the soundlite here
well it's official i'm on cameo for all
your happy birthday messages your
anniversary
well make sure you disappear
that was good that was really good does
it make you uncomfortable
then
it's a little creepy but i think it's
more funny than anything okay good sport
yeah
it's all in good fun
you said you've been gotten getting a
lot of requests about
clyden's klein water and you've been
rejecting them yeah
yes i will i will not play that there
are certain things i will not do that's
proof of your dedication right because
that's money you're saying turning down
money it's yeah no dollar you know could
could make no amount no no
it's too far
a little more update ab apparently saved
the family from a car exploding
what yeah did you hear about this hello
no
now there's a theory in the office that
he actually set the car on fire
because there's way too much [ __ ] going
on around aby's life
we're like was james charles in the car
he's like i saved james charles from a
burning car let's play the video and
then you could unpack it for us he's
trying to help the family right now but
i'm so scared
so what's happening i don't know
the car is smoking
wow
oh my gosh
it was just in flames what's happening
it was inflamed
oh i see the flames kind of hit
me
wow
oh man i was literally so scared for you
what is happening here
oh my god how did that happen
you bailed the [ __ ] out of there that
way baby
i got
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so what was your involvement
well you know after we left that night
after mr verified i'm like there's no
way i'm beating ian and then i saw the
fight i'm like hold on lena wait a
second oh i'd be able to uh
to swing the boat if i save these kids
from this burning car
and
i ran in in my tuxedo
and there was a little girl there oh you
know the real story started i'm gonna
even lost my [ __ ] but no we were
just driving home that night and we saw
a little girl on the side of the highway
without her parents
and so me and lena were like freaking
out and some cars were stopped i went
around the meeting got in front of them
got out lena stayed with the little girl
and the parents were trying to get an
infant out the infant was still in a car
seat yeah wow so i was i was telling the
mom the mom was kind of freaking out i
just said go with the daughter but she
didn't speak good english
she went over with lena and me and the
dad got the infant out wow and then they
didn't want to [ __ ] leave i was
telling them to get in the car get in
our car or at least step further back
and they're just the dad's like slowly
grabbing the stroller and just like
they're unpacking at the mall or
something very casual yeah and then when
i saw other people walking up alright
[ __ ] this i mean i don't i don't know
what to do at this point i mean we got
the kids out
he be the hero
wow
[Applause]
take a bow baby
stand up yeah
you're a good man he's also a superhero
at night
you're a good man to pull over and help
yeah
i like that
thank you
he made sure to record it though
[Laughter]
[ __ ] god of you
[Laughter]
so lena recorded and honestly hold on
let me finish lena recorded and then i
got after lena was outside with me first
okay lena got back in the car
lena recorded and i had no idea that she
was recording until after when she was
playing oh you were recording and then i
was like
damn i really wish you kind of got the
beginning
[Laughter]
you still did really good that's really
really nice of you thank you
but listen listen the reason why i have
to record is no one believes [ __ ] around
tonight
well after the james charles [ __ ] yeah
we didn't improve
[Laughter]
but
okay i i took
it's a bad big bite
dude these are the best breakfast
i'm almost done you guys they messed up
with mine they put bacon on mine so i
can't eat it
well i gave you the chorizo one stop no
you stopped no you're not even cute
says who
oh my god
i'll just take a bite thank you you're
hello
i would have given you mine i would have
traded you oh that one's not the bacon
one that one's chorizo
oh i don't know oh so eat it
that's what i said
oh my god
baby eats like a an elementary school
okay
you can eat it
yeah as long as there's no bacon
i'm good
is that your rule no pork there's no
pork yeah it's all hollow like
all of us half-assed muslims to do it
do you drink alcohol
no i used to when i was younger
but
did you stop for religion
uh pretty much yeah but also i married
him
yo it's no fun breaking news but we just
got a super chat for 44
no 45 british pounds i'm finally
speaking out
i was a paid actor in the fake ab car
story
he told me and my family to act panicked
and his girlfriend filmed us
what do you have to say for yourself
okay don't let my wife know i have a
girlfriend
oh right
i think they meant lena
[Laughter]
baby you're gonna have to provide proof
that you didn't fake it that's how it
works on conservative media
right
right
hey i mean was that burrito shiritso the
shot is going crazy
shiritso is pork
chorizo oh chat's
olivia what are you doing it's your
first day you're trying to make me
change my career
take it back bring it back bring it back
well who's like the bacon one wait so
there's cherry chocolate yeah who's got
the bacon you know i had that thought
but i don't eat meat so i'm far from an
expert on chorizo so i was like oh okay
here let me do a sample test okay can
everyone please remind me who's pregnant
no what
oh my gosh
go cut away cut away oh my
no that's the opposite of what we want
no the end no
yeah it's in the fridge i'll take this
home take another bite wait what is this
one
oh my god everyone is still crazy baby
there we go oh my god
[Laughter]
oh
wow
oh
yeah right
baby no
[ __ ] baby no
holy [ __ ]
that bacon is insane people are still
spamming chorizo somebody take that one
too
[Laughter]
[Music]
baby now
[Music]
i'm back
now you can't eat for like five minutes
oh you can't talk for fresh okay this
whole [ __ ] job
to get a bite of bacon
so vegan is completely out of the
question for today
and the
other day with the shawarma i'll be
honest though i think the meat is too
heavy
i like the egg the vegetarian one better
okay
yeah
which is still not vegan because it's
egg
who said no vegan today okay
maybe tomorrow
so anyway
congratulations to ap he's a hero
just for the record i i do believe this
story
wow
uh i have another revelation here i have
100 uh aed i'm sorry i'm not sure what
currency that is
uh i also have something to confess i2
was a paid actor in the video i was the
burning car that a b purposely lit on
fire for the clout
wow
damning evidence uh yeah i just i
appreciate zach believing in me but it's
funny that we're at a point where a
[ __ ] burning car with the whole
family well i didn't see the car all i
saw was you running quickly from a car
and boning out yeah actually we just
pulled up like lena recording real quick
yeah i ran up i'm like good luck idiots
and then i ran back that's what it
looked like i don't know what you said
to them
you may have just said burn
we don't know what really happened
without the video evidence
fire yeah congratulations ava you are a
hero thank you thank you i also wanted
to clear something up i've seen a lot of
speculation about why we ended families
and people there's all these there's
speculation there's conspiracy there oh
wow i really love the internet so i
haven't i've been watching a lot of t
channels i'm not gonna
but the speculation is that
and it's and it's true
is that we ended
families to protect my parents from the
internet which is absolutely true
coming off of like
my mom's beef with trisha
[Music]
and just like and and then like
how they getting into stuff with people
on twitter yeah they don't need this and
they're their retirement in their old
age it's taking like the mix of like
working with family to a next level
because it's not just work with family
it's like also online beef
i loved working with them for the record
we had a great my parents were fantastic
they were just grateful and happy to be
there but i just they don't know
they don't know what they're getting
themselves in how dark it can get right
and i saw it tipping a little bit over
the course of 10. where there's people
who are like saying bad nut mean things
and then you have trisha stands saying
mean and it's like and it's just it gets
kind of icky and my parents are
wholesome they're pure they've been
through their life they don't need to be
on the internet and people saying these
horrible things and then wait till
people start making exposed videos about
them digging into their past i mean you
can only imagine you know [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
friday [ __ ] like i said on the thank you
mom
so like i said on the show i wanted to
end on a high note when everything was
pure and beautiful
and not wait for the exposed videos
that's a good reason yeah
then
it can get really dark when you're in
like
i mean she was like you know she was
talking about drama stuff and like it
can be funny for a little bit but if you
guys continue in that route yeah it's
only going to get more and more dark for
her on like
she doesn't want to have people hating
her on the internet okay and then or
worse if you know or worse there's worse
things that could happen yeah much worse
things and you know
trisha was like literally calling my mom
out and i was like oh this is gone this
is too much
and you know i put my mom in that
position so i'm not i'm not blaming it's
my fault you know i had my mom comment
on drama which i thought would be funny
to have this naive sweet lady who
doesn't know anything about the internet
but the thing is like the show is a big
platform so yeah that's the thing it's
not like a goofy little
dubrick
is your brick
but she said like my mom is like vile
and the most evil
woman alive and people pick up on that
stuff and run with it all the way and
say he says you know what
let's wrap it up while we're ahead
exactly and it is true that we only
started it as a group like it was going
to be
one episode at first yeah and it was
just one up yeah so yeah but so people
were so receptive to everything that we
were like let's roll with it for a while
but
and also on the back end it was very
difficult show to produce
just for up for like to generate ideas
and stuff because
um
it's like it's kind of
they're old they're boomers and they're
out of place so it's like there's a
stick that you have kind of
a space to work in that i think
over the course of another 10
20 episodes would probably start to
wear off so i want the novelty to be
fresh i want people to like my parents i
don't want people making exposed videos
on my parents or worse
everyone's happy in the end right
that's right there you have it
you know we have an upper band this is a
hard decision for me to make because
it was ethan was going back and forth
for a couple weeks
it's really hard because first of all
despite everything it was still like our
most viewed podcast
after after dark i guess after dark yeah
but but like consistently over a million
views yeah no and we had like ads out
the ass like the advertisers loved that
family [ __ ] yep so you know it was a lot
of money to say no to
and a lot of people who are enjoying the
show a lot of content
but
it was um the right decision i think
you know indeed
for their tender hearts
so that's that
uh we should do our ad read oh for real
already it's worth 35 minutes in that
went fast okay yes indeed
thank you thank you peace and love to
hello fresh
hello fresh hello french do you love
hello fresh sheila i do i think it's
great actually
because i never know what to cook
or
i just get
i get frustrated by even having to think
about what to cook yeah and figuring
that out you got to go to the grocery
store yeah you got to pick at the right
ingredient so
it saves you all the thinking that's
what i like and just the joy and
pleasure of cooking a delicious meal
that's the beauty fall is busy but hello
fresh recipes save time you'd otherwise
spend meal planning shopping chopping
and you get to do what matters is which
is cook a beautiful delicious healthy
meal
wham bam hello fresh family friendly
menu is a big one for back to school
season with easy delicious recipes for
drama free drink dinners hellofresh
offers 50 manual market items to choose
from every week from vegetarian meals
and calorie smart choices to extra
special gourmet options there's
something for everybody to enjoy with
best recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure deliciousness and
simplicity
yeah i mean there's and like the variety
of stuff they send you is is amazing
they've got like mexican food they got
pizza they got
awesome it's always good too
here and then we've got a fantastic
offer you guys ready for this
if you go to hellofresh.com
it after dark 14
and use code after dark 14 you're going
to get up to 14 free meals wow
including free shipping
once again that's hellofresh.com
after dark 14 and use code after dark 14
for 14 up to 14 free meals
it's uh you know hey it's hellofresh
america's number one meal kit thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
honey thank you honey
we love our sponsors don't we you like
you know about honey i do i sometimes
regret when i shop on my phone because
i'm like i don't know right you know
honey could have saved me money
but
they saved me so much money every time i
shop basically i always check it and
sometimes there's a pretty good saving
what is honey it's a browser plug-in
you can install into easy clicks it's
free to use
it scours the web for promo codes
automatically
adds them at checkout if there's any
applicable codes
it's so easy to use it supports over 30
000 stores online ranging from tech
gaming products fashion brands even food
delivery
and it applies the best coupon in a few
seconds
um
it's magic literally magic all you gotta
do is watch the price drop
i mean i can't i can't recall the amount
of times that we've been shopping online
minding our own business not even
thinking about coupon codes yeah ready
to check out pay full price honey's like
nah
you ain't paying full price for that
not happening not son
and save like fifty fifteen hundred
bucks honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
folks
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free installs in
a few seconds and by getting it you're
gonna be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast thank you thank
you i wouldn't recommend something i
don't use and trust me we use honey
everywhere
get honey oh we got a savings do we
saved 111 what was this for that was uh
from levi's.com
dude that's like 50
yeah i mean this happens to me a lot i'm
not even not even kidding get honey for
free at jordanhoney.com h3ad that's join
honey.com
h3ad we love you
and finally kraken you know we love you
kraken
hey guys if you're interested investing
in cryptocurrencies but aren't sure
where to get started check out the
kraken app with kraken you can buy and
sell over 50 of the most popular cryptos
like bitcoin dogecoin and ethereum on
the go 24 7. it's super easy to get
started just download the app create
your account and you'll be investing in
minitos minitos
did they write that they wrote minutes
okay
one of the coolest things about buying
crypto through kraken is that you don't
need a lot of money to try it out so
even if bitcoin is worth something like
40 000 you can buy as little as 10 bucks
worth on kraken just to get your feet
wet see how you like it
find out yourself why kraken has been
one of the highest rated places to buy
crypto for the last 10 years visit
kraken.com after dark to learn more or
search for kraken in the app store and
guys once again i like to emphasize
kraken friend of the show
jesse powell was on the show he had a
great appearance he's a great guy and
kraken is one of the most trusted
companies in the game so if you're
interested in crypto please uh consider
using kraken kraken.com after dark thank
you thank you
[Music]
all right
this is [ __ ] great look at this [ __ ]
you know we always talk about kevin hart
because of the ryan yeah kavanaugh [ __ ]
this showed up on my feed
right uh uh kevin hart is showing up on
shark tank which is another show i love
yeah but they made such a hilarious
blunder
in their promoting of him
that uh so they're technically saying is
like a guest judge he's a guest judge
okay
is he even an entrepreneur you know what
i mean he's just a rich um sort of
i don't know much about his business but
i mean he's very rich
i'm sure he has some investments
probably
well check this out this girl
this is fantastic look at this [ __ ] whoa
this is crazy uh the official shark tank
abc instagram account just announced
that kevin hart is gonna be a guest
shark on shark tank
uh he's the founder of air reel
i've never heard of that before i'm
gonna look it up oh okay yeah kevin hart
the ceo of ariel
except uh
this isn't the right kevin hart no
uh
no
that's not kevin hart somebody on the
shark thanks social media team is
getting in there is that awesome oh my
god
it's kevin hart he's the ceo of ariel
he's got credentials wow
i wonder if they hired the wrong kevin
hart
wow
who messed that up the producers are
like let's get kevin hart on the show
yeah okay great
and then they got they get kevin hart
shows up on set and they're like oh [ __ ]
we got the wrong kevin hart
well somebody was probably preaching
this guy kevin hart and then the other
people thought that's the kevin hart but
i'm wondering if they yeah they actually
got the wrong kevin hart yeah i think so
that's the best and kevin hart is like
super excited he's like cool
oh my god i'm not an entrepreneur but i
like the respect they're giving me
the wrong one wow
like so kevin hart ceo
it would still be a really fun episode
if they got kevin hart the real so wait
you think they don't have
you think they got the ceo kevin hart
and they posted a comedian kevin art no
i think no no i think they got the
comedian kevin hart but they
think that that is his investment
see i'm trying to see if this other
kevin hart is even a big wig maybe you
guys can i'm not seeing much information
about
it's awesome what was the name of the
company again it was uh
it's not amazing that's fantastic trying
to think but nothing happens
i'm kind of souring on shark tank to be
honest i used to write
yeah and lately it's like every picture
is just
a little repetitive so dumb dude oh my
god how many years have they been doing
that now i feel like that shows uh a lot
i don't know it's like season 11 or 12
well i just don't understand why there's
no there's no good entrepreneurs left in
this country
i personally feel like the good ones
probably actually have better
options out there than going on shark
tank because they do ask for a lot of
money like the percentage they ask for
is a lot they rip they rip rip people
yeah
yeah that's a good point if you actually
have a pop in business yeah
right
i just watch it for the cubes mark cuban
is the man
the key you're one of the cubans
cubes
your cute boy i feel like it
goes to his head too much and it's like
oh everyone wants cuban
i don't know i'm gonna put this in the
mavericks locker room yep
this is great and he always plays it
like
i don't care until the last minute and
then he's like he throws some offer and
everyone jumps on it like yes
we wanted you you know what you know
what i really hate
it i know they're doing it for theatrics
but it's so [ __ ] up is that when
someone's pitching something someone
gets an offer right they go i'm giving
you this offer and you have to answer if
you even look at another show i will
spit on you and i'll do everything in my
power to make sure you fail that's
another reason why
real people with a real business
shouldn't even go like why shouldn't i
hear what everyone else has to offer
that's a good business move i shouldn't
hear all the offers
it's
like what are you promoting
contradictory type of person you want to
work with you want to work with a shrewd
businessman yeah are you telling me a
shrewd businessman it's like just shut
up and be your [ __ ] take it right now
or the offer is off the table yeah and
then they just look at someone else and
it's like okay i'm out
you
i'm
out
offer from mr cuban and you didn't take
it well he does the buzzer beater where
he counts three seconds down
i find that so disrespectful and i don't
like the shtick i'm actually interested
in the business it kind of ruined the
show for me they started doing it more
and more it's like every [ __ ] show
you know you know what i'm out it's like
you petty you're like how insecure are
you guys
i'm after can i consult with my partner
think about it no i'm out like what the
[ __ ] what are you trying to promote well
then they'll also they're like can i
make a quick call and then they'll step
out of the tank and then they'll come
back and they'll offer come back the
offer gets worse it's totally [ __ ]
we've
changed the offer yeah pray we don't
change it further yeah
it's like i don't know
you know the same thing can be said for
what's that one show we liked
the prophet the prophet i loved that
show did anyone ever watch that
he got such a big he went so big time he
was this guy he was an entrepreneur he
would go into failing businesses and
like just really gut it and rework it it
was so entertaining i loved it so much
and in the new seasons he went like big
time it's like he's trying to become a
a celeb like
him himself as a character or something
i don't know he's trying to build up his
personality as a celeb i feel like and
it's just like not working but it's way
less about the businesses yeah or just
about him yeah and i'm like
no anyway shout out to kevin hart the
studio
hey uh real quick before we move on uh
there have been a lot of questions in
the chat about
uh what happened to the new love bot
including a 50 super chat from alicia
saying hey what happened to the new love
bot after the returning to youtube skit
he's still with the broken screen what
happened to the new lovebot is that
thing sucked oh really yeah horrible
speaker
vastly inferior product and you guys
might notice that looking at love on the
screen you couldn't really even see the
screen was so dim on the old one like
this one you can really make it and the
battery wasn't holding a charge
within minutes of being off the charger
the horizontal screen wasn't good either
yeah everything started
the fika vibe was way off yeah
yeah completely off completely to be
honest to be totally honest like with
this robot i really feel like love is in
here with them right now but the other
one i didn't feel his presence yeah so
even with the broken screen this this
one is vastly superior
absolutely yeah
it was laggy too like at times it we
like he we would hear him and then his
visual was like 10 seconds behind like
it was like that behind it was a bad
product yep
what do you guys think about this
team skeet
giving a fun farewell to my dad on the
ending of her family
in honor of h3 families closing the
curtains we are doing one more team ski
ufo shirt giveaway that's the one they
gave my dad apparently
follow us on tw oh yeah smash that like
button
for a chance to win your very own gary
klein porn ambassador uniform
smash that like button please stand up
apparently someone out team skeet's a
fan of the show yeah this is so [ __ ]
fun
and they gave the peace and love too
there's all kinds of memes in there look
how happy my dad looks
smash that like by the way this is when
i got really ela tell me what you think
about this
okay here's like oh god you know what
you know
i watched him today on the podcast he's
so adorable
you know my dad responded he said you're
not too bad
yourself no this is mine no right no
after all we've been through on this on
our show gary still
i mean he's flirting
in public view and smash that like
button your dog
you're not so bad yourself dad stop it
gary i love you
i guess you'll have to get in line like
don't even don't stop it dad that's not
it's i don't like this
this is why i entered the show you guys
understood this is the problem
yeah this is why the show is ending
if you want to blame anyone blame my dad
for these tweets
smash that like button
i literally can't deal with this [ __ ]
yeah well speaking of my dad i
okay dan you ready okay
you guys
me and dan have been scheming in secret
i know what it is
hold on
okay
me and dan have been devising a secret
loyalty test uh-oh
you guys have been going on and on about
your cameos my mom my dad all you guys
on cameo
talking about well cameo cameo this came
with that is it okay
let's use cameo
to do a loyalty test so what we did did
you know about this ela i told you about
it right
we bought a cameo from each one of these
guys
emperor and we asked them to insult me
[Laughter]
we wrote to them and said i don't like
ethan
you're my favorite i watch because of
you can you insult ethan
and and so we've given each one of these
guys and both of my parents
a loyalty test
now there's one person that failed
spectacularly i would say right
uh well
i guess say i don't know it's not
spectacular nobody went all in i'll say
that like nobody
was like yeah ethan [ __ ] suck
um there was one but definitely did
better than others there's one fail
was there just one fail or was there
more than one uh there's two that i
would probably classify as a fail
um
and then two like neutral and then one
that actually i would say passed with
flying called they excelled
okay do you want you guys want to guess
who failed
i can't guess because i already kind of
know some of it
um
wait tell me tell me who's the other i
know which one is but
they're gonna hear
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course
well you guys want to take a guess i
mean guys who do you think are you guys
surprised you guys are just for now
finding out maybe just said that you
think not surprised
that's not what i yeah i was wrong oh
okay what do you think it was the
imagine thing
no i think i thought it was this but i
don't i totally went past my head for
this one i was expecting this anytime i
got like a weird request but this one
was so i did not expect this to be i
tried to be subtle and i think for the
most part i was successful but in my in
my defense
actually let's just watch it first go
ahead
no no okay oh so abe knows he failed
a b of all the people you [ __ ] failed
me dude you lost your sim card the one
who suspected that it might happen too
you [ __ ] felt no he said he didn't
suspect it he respect he had he he was
tingling he was anticipating all kinds
of [ __ ] by the way this was a really
elaborate scheme
dan made several different accounts sent
them at different times during the week
because they all gossip backstage so we
had to make sure that nobody knew nobody
talked about it and every and we sent
them all at different times
with different names from different
email accounts yeah they made like yeah
this was a very elaborate sting
and i actually even
we both got these weird cameos and and
we had a conversation we were like
this is ethan isn't it and it was not
different that was you okay and it was
not you so i am also very surprised i i
got one that i i thought for sure was um
yeah you guys um without specifics they
just wanted me to meow
what i thought no that wasn't yeah there
was no meow
over there
i have been scheming on ways to
embarrass you guys via cameo but the
loyalty test was the one
you're making it's not a lot worse than
what it is i think you should show it if
anything well hold on we'll get it we
will
but in my defense
i just had a shoe chucked at my my
tracheal i could i could not breathe
wasn't that what are you talking about
where was he submit his video how's that
related yesterday it happened this
morning what do i care if it's sure i'm
saying that was a video before i
recorded the one about you
oh you're mad at me you're taking it out
on me i'm just saying i was a little uh
excuse
[Music]
you me bro
does this mean i can reclaim the number
one simp uh potentially let's see i've
said all along love you're the next guys
remember
you can take this into consideration
when you vote during missiles
it all counts it all counts
a b got a big boost from saving that
child from a burning car so this might
balance that out yeah well [ __ ] the kids
in the burning car you dissed me dude
it's the original sin can you post it
now dan the uh
oh it's in the discard
all right
you know what i thought it was at first
i thought you found that speech dan that
i was telling you yeah oh yeah no no no
i look
so should i play all of them or just the
ones that failed and then the one that
was like passed with flying colors are
they all interesting they're all i mean
you don't have to watch all of them your
dad's is like seven minutes long or
something so obviously you have to watch
that one but but
so this is the person that passed with
flying colors i want to play this one
first okay who do you think it was the
past you can ask me because i know
and you guys want to guess
i think zac
it's also his parents just so you guys
know you guys was my mom my mom passed
with flying colors
my mom
came to ride for me
here is my mom on the loyalty test
just go ahead
hey steve it's donna from families you
are so sweet
you know i've had the best time because
you said you're my favorite and i
watched videos
and that i was very upset that families
was ending and i didn't really like the
h3 pockets but it was a huge donna fan
uh and i really just watched for her not
even yeah
the podcast with gary had been and um
yeah but you know it's just yeah no zach
passed
yeah but zach cheated
this whole network and family on this
social media platform and you know
i am not going away i'm still going to
be on twitter and tick tock just too
long
give ethan a chance he's got some really
good stuff he's a smart guy he's funny
and um
i can't tell you who the next guest is
going to be but is that all because it's
a surprise you get the job
she was like stick with me give ethan a
chance he's a great great
thank you
so you're saying well okay so zach you
know i'll tell zach did pass and i'll
tell you why he's the only one that
didn't submit and so i was like zach
check your cameos you gotta do this
before the show i was like we sent you a
cameo
but talk but i said talk [ __ ] about me i
said just go in and say mean things
about me and zach looked me and he's
like i can't do that
even when i specifically instructed him
i said zach you have to just say bad
things about me oh he's not getting bad
he's like i can't wait so the request
was just sitting there and yeah he
didn't get to it he didn't get to
because he had so many big guys
so zach refused but i said okay just
film something
this is a link to
you know this is the wrong thing
um
so i don't actually don't know what he
sent but
this whatever he sent was
knowing that uh he was being uh
bamboozled yeah so it doesn't really
count but he did pass maria maria
what is up it is what is going on it is
zach the sound lab
first off thank you so much for the love
and support buying a cameo from me very
cool of you
um just remember he knows what's up
people on the show and you know with the
sound bites and stuff but
i just want to feel right dunking on
ethan first of all i have nothing bad to
say about the man
i always tell people i have the best job
in the world you know this is
been amazing working here and
just for the record i wouldn't
i hope you know me where i wouldn't
bad-mouth you i would have rejected it
it was a test i would have rejected that
yeah well
i guess it will never be fair i i mean i
strong guard zach more than anyone
because i literally said to him go take
the cameo and just talk [ __ ] about me
he said i can't do that i said okay you
passed the test is it golden boy what
can you say nothing bad to say
certainly not
okay okay so then we have um
i don't want to keep closing this
document so we have basically the
failures now
and and ian you want to watch ian's i
don't know yeah yeah ian hey maria this
is ian here i got your camera four
minutes and
you were hoping this cut to the chase is
it right here
wait i thought it was just about to
absolutely give my best roast to ethan
just the best roast i've got
and you know as you enjoyed the roast
previously i see why you would come to
me for this request uh it sounds like
you're a little bummed out with the
ending of certain shows that we've done
in the past so i get why you'd want me
to uh
give him
my best roast and uh
sure
sure maria i will totally be up for
doing that um gotta get on with it
let me get the head space okay here we
go heads face here all right
best roast
for ethan clyde
all right
i am going to say
that
for ethan klein
i think my best roast would probably be
folger's classic
always oh never misses ian never missed
very good now ian let me ask you did you
suspect that this was a trap
i actually didn't wow i i thought you
were someone else that was in my queue
but i didn't know i am so you all
suspected i was in your queue yes they
all suspected that you were doing it but
but none of them caught on that my
request was the one so wait which is the
one that you thought was me ian
uh i got one where someone said
that he just broke up with his
girlfriend but he wanted me to send him
a special birthday message
to his ex and i thought that was you
like some gag
interesting
not me
but it's interesting that you didn't
roast me so were you just trying to do a
play on words or were you actually just
not wanting to roast your magnanimous
boss
i feel like i let it all out at the
actual roast i got nothing left
i expect i didn't know what to expect
with ian you know well he passed the
test
yeah he passed he actually did pass nice
and that leaves us of course with the
big
fails
a b and my dad
team skeet baby
so let's start with a b
hello reba thank you for reaching out
thank you for showing support thank you
for watching the show
uh you asked me to
dunk on ethan but see it's not it's not
easy to dunk on ethan because he's
nearly perfect okay i mean come on the
guy he's he's always on time
that's another way
he speaks his pronunciation of words
that's a [ __ ] beautiful inspiration
he never messes up and
it's honestly like poetry whenever he
speaks
the guy is really committed
uh he wears shorts every day
it's my show
i don't i don't i don't believe what you
wear
i can wear shorts he will not break his
principles
he will always wear those
shorts of his
and
lina
lina
what can i make fun of ethan for you're
roping lena into this now what can i be
trying ethan is this just lazy or you
act was this planned ask her
these are my cameos i'm doing it before
work i don't i mean wow bro bro and baby
wonders why he's got no orders
you work a lot bro that's it that's the
real [ __ ] i'm literally wearing the same
thing
i was wearing glasses i literally just
woke up
and my eyes looked super red also when
lena hit me with that slipper on the
previous cameo i think it made my eyes
more red so
but dude this is a big [ __ ] l
bro you could you're just gonna go out
and roast me
wait what does lina say i want to see
good point all right
nothing she's like what are you doing
what are you talking about i'm like
doing [ __ ] no she said something oh
he gets diarrhea a lot
that's nobody's business this guy
charges five dollars more than me
do you i was charging a lot more than
that but yeah i tried to find more than
that
but they pay for the authenticity what
can i say should you guys put on the
show i give them the realness
that's a giant l bro
dude that is such a backstab to me
after everything i've done do you
getting getting paid
you i am whatever you say i'm you say
i'm the symbol i said okay yeah
whatever i mean i just i just go with
the character no
i know it was you
i did give you this job
i do everything i do everything for
you and now you're on cameo taking money
to insult me on this very special thing
what did i do to deserve this treatment
from you
ab you are like my son
and now you're nothing
now you are nothing to me
you brought me on you broke my heart
baby i have a counter argument
okay
we will hear it okay
weren't these guys all working for you
during a certain time
and did any of them make an hour and a
half video defending you
no
i think there's a cloud argument for
that
see
yeah whatever
like i said i am whatever you say i am
i'm the clown goblin because i'm it was
obviously agreed with that yeah i wasn't
safe i want clown i should have
definitely went the other way yeah
because yeah i would definitely listen
to that that video didn't get used for
[ __ ] two years going against all the
the club of uh hate yeah it's uh not an
hour and a half long
hour 15 minutes look that up a little
bit
critiquing him now
all right you know i kid you i love you
you are simp and uh you're the greatest
honestly it wasn't that bad no i mean
come on dude i'm just kidding did you
see what happened to me before that the
camera before that or at least i have to
do it no i did not lina chuck
with the shoe excuse what is
i wouldn't have talked [ __ ] if if i
hadn't been hit by a shoe what did you
say i said what does that have to do
with this i don't understand uh
zach has asked you what does that story
have to do with this do you want to
respond
it just threw me it threw me off a
little bit i wasn't thinking straight
after that i saw my life flash before
you rattled your brain the shoe is
concussed
therefore you have to talk [ __ ] about
your boss
zach has a zac has a question i think
the merits and answers you don't have to
smoke today bro i love you man don't get
me wrong why do you make me do this
go ahead speak your mind maybe
no i'm good
peace and love to all there's some i'm
the hero i save the kids is there
something you're holding back about zach
no no no no okay
can i abbey and i took a really nice
photo yesterday can i show that real
quick
yeah
backtracking real quick
adorbs where you can't yeah
beautiful yeah things can change so fast
all right here's my dad who basically
was the biggest fail of all
no surprises
i was kind of surprised my dad so where
should i start because this is five
[ __ ] minutes long holy [ __ ] it's not
that far in that and
next time my dad tries to tell me he's
busy i'm gonna show him this five minute
cameo
like aps it's you know it's not like
he's like [ __ ] ethan he sucks
[Laughter]
all right here we go yeah
gary from the
late great can you crack his podcast on
h3
i am as you well know the father of
ethan the husband of the don arc kind of
reminds me of shoes
thank you so much for your cameo i've
done quite a few so far and you are
hands down my favorite cameo request so
far
because
like don as i said i don't really like
ethan i really just watched the show for
you i watch for you i got gary kleiner
for life i believe i said and
he goes this is my favorite cameo
to defend ap real quick this is your
father
saying this [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
this is any i mean that's horrible
you just showed
excellent taste in um preferring me over
my son and uh
my uh
style of child rearing
and uh
you know it's been interesting to see oh
that's right i also i said i made a
comment about um it's so annoying how
ethan always complains about how you
raised him
[Laughter]
the debates ethan and i have had
once he started therapy
uh
dude oh my god
excuse me
this is awful
[Laughter]
dad is responsible for anything bad
that's ever happened to me and you know
that is basically
what uh in the podcast ended up being
about for for quite a while so
um
you know he's a good kid i think
everyone after listening to this my
dad's definitely the biggest i think
anything i said about you
i think you guys need an emergency
episode
[Laughter]
i i retract anything bad i said about av
my dad is definitely the big l on this
one
[Laughter]
and
as a special reward for being my
favorite cameo
this is i believe the only one i've done
is sans hat
so you are getting to see
what a tree
is
still looking you did it without a hat
oh wait he took off the h3 hat
for this one
imagine
nice
anymore anything else you want to say
about my therapy you know donna was a
super successful hair stylist for many
years
and i just went on
to be honest i didn't watch much further
i was like all right i got the idea
because as you said you know we have no
[ __ ]
my dad is having a full-on conversation
with him
oh right he just quoted another i said i
love that you have no [ __ ] to give and
he just he just quoted that part
nonsense that happens i need that
there's no effect see i sculpted
um seeing
people saying you know they're going to
miss us and that guys have just been so
great
backlash all right now he's hard for
fans i don't know if you expected this
much backlash it was like when we did
the family feud episode
and
my dad was playing his whole life
you know ethan and i kind of thought
this was going to bring milk weed and
story time with really enjoyed it
favorite cameo like you are reba
reba
you know identify yourself as someone
to talk to me so i'm not quite different
um
i don't know where you live where you
are but hopefully it's a belief and stay
healthy so please thanks again love you
guys take care and we will
see you soon bye-bye
awesome
i killed it gary
sorry gary sorry to do you like that i
need that clown i was under specific
orders
somehow
you underestimate a little bit i think
it's a good thing
i can't believe your dad said that [ __ ]
oh my god
it doesn't bother if you think that it's
gonna bother me or cause problems it's
not it's just a funny guy i don't want
people to actually get worried don't
open
please
yeah don't worry about it please
i love my dad there's not is it trust me
any problem i have with my dad's already
been like
what about me you know aired out rushed
over rolled over maybe i'm gonna talk to
you after this show
well that was fun
oh another uh breaking news that i have
to share jojo uh just confessed uh i
have a confession
i was a paid actor in abey's cameo i was
the sh i was the shoe zach paid me to
sabotage a b
so he was the shoe yeah the shoe that
got thrown at a b
that he was awesome so yeah the
possibility that the shoe that was
thrown at you has called all caused all
the misfortune of this week yeah the
comments said the shoe knocked the simp
out of me
so guys we're moving on now
to
fortnite is out of control for this one
this might be my favorite story of the
year
yeah we planned a lot for it too it's
gonna be a lot of fun for tonight for so
fortnight for tonight i thought it would
be a good idea
to add mlk
to fortnite yes martin luther king jr
right yeah he's the june he's the junior
yes now
the fact the idea first of all i i
understand it's an admirable mission
they're showing
his in his famous speech you know
yeah about uh i have a dream speech
and the idea is admirable it's a
beautiful speech it's nice to to get
people to watch it
but the idea that a room full of serious
people could come
together and decide to do this is truly
mind bending fortnite
so they added a whole virtual
level where you can
complete various challenges in honor of
mlk's work and civil rights movement
[Laughter]
uh last year
last year this isn't the first time they
dipped their toes in civil issues last
year they actually held a virtual
discussion on race
following the george floyd oh murder
here's a clip of that as a little
refresher i didn't know about this
what is this
yeah okay so so they're in fortnite
watching fortnite
uh they're getting education on race
yep just chilling there and
the fortnight skins
that's wild dude
there's it looks like there's five
people watching
it's so weird yeah i mean it's just guys
it's like i don't know if it's
but anyway this one they took it to the
next minecraft also interestingly did a
civil rights education course course
featuring john lewis
and nelson mandela they made skins of
them
you're going to love this
here's skins here's nelson mandela skin
and minecraft travel to pakistan to meet
malala who spoke out against the taliban
when they tried to prevent girls from
getting an education talking about help
her rebuild the village school and learn
more about her work as an advocate for
education this is dystopian as [ __ ]
we then visit south africa
[Music]
on to segregation that was minecraft but
ammo the mlk event takes the kick right
like this thing is next oh yeah no the
minecraft one is funny but
it's less maybe a little less offensive
this this this fortnite thing is okay so
beyond the same going to a portal into
mlk world
but the problem is of course is that
there's all these dances and skins in
fortnite and it just turns into such a
[ __ ] show here's a little bit of a
lincoln memorial as master
chief of our republic
wrote the magnificent words
beautiful
let's get a little weapon
they were signing
[Music]
there's there's more of course this is
just the beginning
this is the worst thing that's ever
happened
so someone someone said mlk had a
had a dream he didn't realize it would
turn into a fort nightmare
[Laughter]
nice one here's another one everyone
celebrating the great words of martin
luther king
[Applause]
[Music]
this is too weird
[Music]
watch for social justice let's keep it
going come on
oh that's it
you want to floss for social justice
hila
uh no
fortnite
here's more
this appears to be
uh what is this skin
[Music]
this is so dark like yeah honestly
[Music]
wait what's i don't understand this
character but it's just like everybody
like there's someone on top of the tv
there's spiderman mlk died for this [ __ ]
and everyone's just like
he died for this [ __ ]
he didn't [ __ ] die for to be his
grave tap danced on
instead of fortnite
it's rewind time
here they are raising oh here's uh
rick raising the roof on him
what i have four little children
they live in a nation where they will
not be judged by the color of their skin
but yes
i have a dream
i have a dream
[Music]
superman and rick sanchez raising the
roof
on mlk
beautiful
this is what he saw
okay can i read you a chat message yes
please okay
with all due respect you guys focus so
much on exposing others and then when
there's an instance of companies
actually raising awareness for such
important things you laugh it's just a
view of his speeches lol listen
i'll take that yeah
that needs addressing listen i said at
the beginning that it's good they're
trying to raise awareness
i love the speech it's good people can
see it but this is a this is a [ __ ] show
it's funny
yeah
it's funny and it's also that's all it's
like and it deserves more reverence than
having [ __ ] rick from rick and morty
doing the floss
in front of his speech like please this
is this is so disrespectful
and it's raising awareness that it that
doesn't outweigh
the
the
harm i don't know i don't know if i
would say it's disrespect i mean it's
the players are in there making memes
out of it which was which was inevitable
inevitable of course like the the
intentions is good it's a violent video
and by the way it's just like this is
not the place for this by the way i'm
sure a lot of people went in there who
hadn't seen it and watched it and
enjoyed it so that's good
but then but like it is funny let's not
debate that it's not funny i mean come
on it's funny is this a real media
picture yes
no they slapped the playstation logo on
his forehead
you know and that well that's just
monetizing a man who wanted to like
kill poverty right like that was a
socialist yeah he wanted to end poverty
and now you have his face on a
playstation
dude that's gnarly that they did that
with the playstation
what is this [ __ ]
oh no is this from the game
yes oh bro the episode wow so wow okay
i didn't realize that they have a
bathroom like back in the day obviously
during jim crow
you have a whites and colored sinks
and um it's kind of actually it's kind
of cool you're doing like a virtual
museum i mean it's actually kind of cool
maybe just the rick and their flossing
maybe what they could have done is just
like cancel skins and dancing
that's exactly could they do that that
would have at least helped them the
memes of uh yeah no but really just
again and and chat probably this would
be my guess
it just feels like it makes a joke of
the
subject of the whole thing exactly
actually
educating i don't know oh man this is
crazy i didn't realize they had like a
whole interactive and they're all in
line to do something they're like peeing
in the corner or something i don't know
what's going on
um
here's a monument i have a dream it
looks like alien from alien predator
is using a typewriter or something
i don't know what the hell is going on
there
uh here's rick and alien i believe he
was taking notes okay
yeah at least he was paying attention uh
picketing
for his dream
i think it's cool i i just think it's
funny i mean you can't tell me it's not
funny
very similar energies of course to shout
out to his family
there's this in case you forgot
is
in honor of george floyd
so
shout out to his family
[Music]
yeah so
anyway we got inspired by this
and um we actually we spoke with
fortnight because we had concerns you
know we had a lot of feedback for them
hilo really
and so we actually prepared well we we
thought it was really effectual
okay so we we suggested
effective effectual
you look that up i think that's a word
maybe not
effectual is a word oh yes
how about that come on
i dare you i said your words like poetry
right don't you're in the you're in the
doghouse baby
don't even try to get on my good side
so you know we we had a long
conversation with the epic games
right yes yeah yes epic games yes yes
and we said listen the mlk thing was
such a success
we want to pitch you guys some other
historical events that we think would be
good in fortnight so here
is our pitch just to raise awareness you
know
so here's our pitch
to
fort for do fortnight so of course we
have the uh september 6th
january it's january 6th
it's not even september yet september
6th uh lincoln assassination
could be cool
[Music]
um for the berlin wall berlin blunder uh
the titanic going down
[Music]
you know
it could be cool to see that oh this is
pearl harbor the bombing
pearl harbor
tiananmen square
you know
yeah
it could be a fun interactive level we
thought okay so this is um this is uh
adolf hitler
uh giving us impassioned
speech bananas are loving that
okay now this is jfk's magic bullet
discover what really happened in this
interactive event
okay wow now this is actually uh this is
a australian
and the banana is running for his life
so
wow yeah those will be coming in the
next few months to the fortnite servers
and the big update
yeah so
those are our pitches and um
they seemed really interested they
seemed to really be very receptive yeah
especially to the last one
before anyone gets mad about the
auschwitz joke that's my joke to tell
okay
ethan insisted he include that one
well
oh
all right well so we've got
after the bathroom break yeah let's do
it i do too you want to go first okay
okay
a donation from mega awesomenerd one of
our mods on the discord actually he said
this is the funniest most tone-deaf
thing i've seen all year
he's talking about the fortnight though
oh it's not uh
no he's talking about the fortnite thing
uh the tone deaf thing i've seen all
year i didn't think mlk's legacy and
struggle to give us rights could be
appropriated anymore but then fortnite
said hold my flossing superman yeah i
mean there you go and he he's a he is a
black man right mega yes right yeah so
yeah um
that's a good point i do think it's like
appropriating it into a video game and
then you're putting the playstation logo
over his face it's like they turned it
into a kind of
i mean they're kind of monetizing it
well it was a free thing they don't
directly make money from it but like a
promotional thing did they like donate
money to
uh no and and i guess you know in
fairness we should say that uh mlk's
estate signed off on it i saw in like
the credits like well thank you thank
you to i mean yeah they wouldn't have
been able to do it otherwise um
so you know they're within their rights
to
license his speech to epic games for
this listen but there's a lot of kids a
lot of people that play fortnite that
maybe don't know about emma cannon's
legacy so
there could be some genuine curiosity
that was the pushback that comes out of
it yeah there was we were talking about
it a lot at the office yesterday um
again i i
i hear the arguments for why it may be a
positive but i just think
the negatives outweigh them in my
opinion
cam brought up a pretty good point he's
like um you know if there's people in
you know
states that have grew up with a racist
family you know this you know informs
them on you know yeah i mean hey i hear
in texas they're banning discussions of
of rate that you can only teach that
that america is a pure and great country
yeah that slave really never happened
that jim crow never happened and maybe
maybe you know it's been a long time
since i was in school so maybe my
perspective is skewed when i was going
to school they taught us about martin
luther king and i have a dream speech
in a serious and appropriate way that
didn't include dancing and you guys
didn't floss during that we did not
stirring that unit
uh
so
you know maybe
in some places they don't do that or now
they're not or or something but you know
i i don't feel like this is necessarily
obscure history that's being
shared and to me it just seems a little
opportunistic exploitive
well it is true that you know when i was
a kid we learned about all that we
learned about like japanese internment
camps we were learned about the native
american trail of tears and the genocide
of native americans we learned about jim
crow and slavery and all the horrible
things about america
and it's like there is an effort
going on now to whitewash america's the
dark underbelly of america's history
true
which is disturbing and horrific it's
like how can you
yeah so maybe maybe this did do some
good somewhere but you can't tell me
it's not absurd it is absurd to see the
master chief dancing oh the how they did
it it's just the
silly part like i saw a couple people
say they could have just played
like a video when you log in or log out
of the game or something like that right
there's also like there's like jumping
puzzles including it and stuff
yeah there was just
there's a lot
i think they got two
i think they got too caught up and
making it cool and like cool and fun
yeah and they're like it wouldn't be
cool if you walked in you're at the
lincoln memorial
and um
i think they goofed a little bit there
it's rewinding so they're definitely
getting some backlash um
from from all corners so
i'd love like a crystal knock walk
through
it's just like being there you get a
yellow star army yeah yeah you're
walking
god you didn't you didn't
yeah
[Laughter]
i do find the whitewashing american
history that a lot of these red states
are trying to do one of the most
disturbing things though that's scary
i've heard it yeah i mean that is
legitimately it's bad it's bad the ap
curriculum does that too when i was in
high school the teacher
like taught us about
how
the curriculum forces you to
whitewashing your answers and ap really
in california yeah when it talked about
um the spanish settlers it just said in
the textbook that they were converting
the native americans but right they
absolutely enslaved them yeah enslaved
them killed them yeah genocide of them
that's ap yeah yeah i mean
i growing up i i remember history like
like you you know talking about jim crow
and segregation and is pretty good on
civil rights
overall
um but the situation with the natives
absolutely was
mega whitewash and that was even here
really oh not at all we learned about
like the genocide we learned about the
trail of tears we learned about all the
wars i learned about that in like eighth
grade but then the ape the apush
curriculum for like all of united states
history it was just
it was pretty ridiculous yeah really
yeah no i felt like my education maybe
you're pretty good i mean it varies from
school to school a little bit i guess
did they make you build a mission
like i didn't i did that kind of stuff
in elementary they maybe no in
elementary school we were we had to
build a model mission which is yeah i
did i did do that in retrospect it
wasn't that it wasn't that serious it
was like just a dumb yeah i mean it was
for fourth grader but that's that's the
point is that's that's that is the
whitewashing is like hey kids it was
this fun little thing let's let's build
a little model of uh i mean the stuff i
remember is learning about how they like
put smallpox and blankets and killed
like hundreds that's true i guess we did
here
all that stuff true that's it dan they
totally made me do that too you did the
mod the model
had my mom and i had to go to joann's
fabrics and get the clay and [ __ ] and
gross
in retrospect it's really [ __ ] up
yes
well listen i actually i don't think
that inherently is like propaganda in
that i mean the settling of california
was a big part of american history like
this that's like specifically california
history how they settled up the coast of
california yeah
and but they don't go into the detail of
what the settling entailed
it wasn't it wasn't so pretty
you know you know what i did learn you
know those bells that are along the 101
freeway yeah we all know zach okay never
mind
i'll just shout
can i ask you guys this what's up has
anyone ever have you guys ever heard
this my teacher in first grade gave us
all bars of soap and told us our
homework was to make bubbles
that explains a lot
sorry my mom yeah my mom like thought
that was the most funny [ __ ] in the
world when i was when i was younger yeah
gave you soap and said make bubbles what
is that when i was super when i was
really young i was living in a very poor
neighborhood okay
hygiene honestly wasn't always the best
and my mom believes that's why they gave
us bars of soap because some of us smell
like didn't smell the bell okay
subtly wow interesting
every time i tell anyone they start they
think it's crazy it is i've never heard
it's pretty weird i've never heard of
that celine elementary
shout out
what was your schooling like because you
grew up in a different state than most
of us here or all of us here i'm well
when i was younger it was bad but when i
moved to a better neighborhood it was a
lot better like when i was in high
school
but when i was younger i felt like i was
like by the time i got to high school i
feel like i was behind everyone else
like i didn't know basic stuff that they
all knew but did you learn about like
native american genocide and all yeah we
learned a lot about uh
stuff like that and civil rights issues
of course um
i like the twilight movies and did you
guys watch did you guys watch twilight i
did watch twilight yeah my first time in
high school
[Music]
dope
people want to hear about the bells
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry sure everybody in
california knows but that's not our
audience i don't know about that i came
on way too strong it's all good i was
rude i was just i'm i'm sorry go ahead
about the bells out put me in my v put
me in my place no no
no there's a lot i have no idea bell
story please there's spamming the bell
emojis i i i was way out of line lay
some knowledge on us okay so the bell is
along the 101 let's pull up some i'll
pull up some photos
zach tell me about the bells okay so
along the 101 el camino yeah yeah so
that that was like the road um
and there they're just bells along the
101 freeway in there they're called the
historic el camino real bells that's it
wait what i thought
okay so
so if you trek up all the way up the
west coast
of
california you'll notice these bells all
along the way okay and it's historic el
camino real this was the first road that
the settler the missionaries made that
connected all the way up this coast of
california that connected the
missionaries
and
and so you'll see these bells all along
like the 101 the one all the way up the
coast of california it marks the
historic el camino real trail you know i
i mean i learned that in fourth grade
i'm like when i was a little fourth
grader i told that to my dad and he had
the same reaction as you did he told me
to shut up
wow
ethan's explanation had a little bit
more details
well i i was just i was just talking
that off off of my head it is cool
though i have a big news ethan yeah
theodore just pooped again on the potty
[Applause]
theodore please don't stand up yeah
there you go
he's had a lot of poop anxiety
we've been potty training him
and um
he's he was totally fine with the pee no
problem
but he would refuse to poop on the potty
just
refuse and he went on a whole weekend
not pooping
until like his stomach started to hurt
and it was scary he wouldn't go to sleep
because he had tummy pain
so we kind of like just
let him uh wear a diaper just to poop
and uh he finally did it hey well last
night it was so funny because
my brother and his fiance are staying
with us and so he finally sat on the
potty and pooped yeah and then we're all
like
theo yeah
and then ela brought up this toy that
she's been saving yeah a special like
fire truck toy for him when he pooped on
the toilet it was like a pop he loves
paw patrol
uh
what's his name marshall marshall
and he it was like oh it's like all
euphoric you got the toy
[Laughter]
yeah
shout out to his family shout out to his
family that's right
uh once again uh real quick some more
breaking news another confession
we have another paid actor in abe's
cameo
it's a b stunt double they took the hit
of the sandal abe didn't actually take
the hit
and they are apparently planning to sue
for emotional distress
you are uh being served right now that's
actually what this message is i'm
observing it right now the notice of
service yeah so so if i'm unpacking that
right you had a body double
that insulted me are you not even doing
your own cameos
i'm so lost at this point yeah i don't
know
i'm conspiracy with him i'm in
conspiracy he's ignorant it goes very
deep he's just conspiracy parents
you just worked so hard that you had to
get a double
actor exactly to do his cameo exactly
isn't crazy might be the only person in
history to try to help a kid from a
burning car
and got made fun of for it
that's what she said
no we were impressed we just have
questions we just have questions i'm
just playing but we were impressed
that really does take balls to do that
yeah for sure yeah jokes aside
no maybe it lasts
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna go to the bathroom
you guys want to talk about the ian why
don't you take the lead are asking if we
want to talk about the nirvana baby
oh yeah sure we didn't prepare for it
but i don't know i'm familiar with it so
the guy who
the inf the very famous cover of nirvana
baby chasing the one dollar bill in a
fish hook yeah
so this guy
is now suing nirvana
saying that he's got lifelong trauma
from being that baby
and i guess there's a an interesting
wrinkle in the story in that like
they didn't even get a consent form from
his parents to use it
oh but then the other interesting but it
was different times maybe i wonder if
like well they were a small band too i
don't think they expected the album to
go like
well not as mega as it did but no they
were on a major label and everything no
uh it they yeah his parents got paid 200
bucks for the photo and like that's it
um which is a little weird considering
it's such an iconic but the rest of the
story
it makes it hard to be sympathetic with
this guy so
um
he also has never mind tattooed across
his chest so the guy
who was basically his whole life up
until now he was like he did a photo
react re recreating the photo and he did
a documentary talking about how he you
know gets jobs and opportunities from
being the kid and how he he's happy that
it was him and he feels fortunate but
apparently like the guy he's like a
musician or an aspiring musician and
like apparently the guys from the band
like stiffed
his band practice he was doing a show
and he invited all the guys and they
didn't show up
and so he's now suing them for not even
that much money either it's like fifty
thousand dollars or something
and uh that's about it i mean he's
clearly here's here's the side by side i
mean he's obviously
just doing a cash grab i mean there's
really no other interpretation
you know
i mean this photo literally if you
didn't tell the world that this was you
nobody would know it was you
like it's just a generic baby
but he spent his whole life being like
that was me
you know it's hard to blame
if there is any kind of trauma
associated with that i mean it's kind of
hard to pin it on nirvana i'm sure but
if you listen he might have he might
have a legal claim i don't know but
it's a hard one to uh digest i guess i'm
curious like
what's his trauma
about it
he is claiming that this
uh photograph constitutes uh
a
cp
i suppose i shouldn't
say it for the sake of the youtube
algorithm but um well i mean okay good
luck with that yeah
i mean look
it is a pretty graphic photo but it's a
baby it's a newborn baby i mean what the
[ __ ] yeah he's saying the dollar makes
him seem like a sex worker
oh right that's part of it
it's an artistic statement that picture
i mean it's still everywhere it's
probably one of the most iconic albums
yeah it is a really iconic photo
i mean um
a sex worker nah come on dude
i don't think anyone interpreted it like
that the fact that he did throughout his
life like
the thing about it is that it only later
you can feel
um i mean like trauma can
you can only sometimes come to terms
with it later it's true and like going
with it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's not feeling that way right now
but i'm also not sure how much
trauma that would cause i have a hard
time
making that
argument for him i mean this looks like
a few month old baby
yeah you're not this is just bro and and
there's just like i said there's no
nobody would know this was you in fact
i don't even wouldn't know that was that
that was you i mean i i just don't know
and then here he's got never mind
tattooed on but okay whatever he he's
playing into it
i just i don't know bro whatever he look
he can sue them i don't give a [ __ ] let
the course i saw some people in the chat
i only got 200 i mean yeah they should
have went back and paid him more i feel
like once it became so famous
yeah and that and
and moreover i i'm seeing some people
say well he should sue his parents if
anything and that's
kind of the 200 bucks well for i mean if
you're putting him in that position
because right because the band he wants
to sue his parents maybe he likes it or
the photographer who originally took it
here's the family part all right make
any sense don't sue your parents
i i think they're just they're just
trying to make the point that like
the band isn't necessarily the people
like if he feels like it is cp
the the band isn't the ones that
chose to do that to him it was his
parents and the photographer that took
the photo i mean look it is a shocking
photo that's why it's so famous right
sure
so maybe there is something there i
don't know
but right now it's just a lot of
speculation
and a lot of
like people just making assumptions
about him and them and that he can i
think he can sue i think it's fine and
they can let the courts figure it out i
mean
it's not like the band can't afford it
it's not like there's some down and out
like they're all [ __ ] rich
yeah think they should get paid more
than 200
for this photo that's one thing i can
say for sure
but
yeah but what can you do i mean let's
just yeah
you can't expect everyone to go back and
just pay people more for [ __ ] i mean
it's not really how the world works yeah
but like i said look he's pr he has an
interesting legal claim so let him work
it out in the court and i'm sure we'll
learn a lot more
once the court once the case goes
through the system
it's interesting that's for sure
yeah
very interesting
you know
one might say it's fascinating i don't
know something something doesn't smell
right i think it smells like team spirit
smells like team spirit
oh god zag makes a joke sometimes i
swear
he's like older than my dad
[Laughter]
i don't think so
hopefully not
i don't think there's anything in there
that
just our discord names and [ __ ] but i
don't think that matters that's all
public anyway in the room yeah exactly
okay
interesting
so we have a actually let's talk about
this you go um
we have a lot to get today it's all good
too oh dude ela i don't know if you've
seen this but elon musk
unveiled
his new robot
the man of the future he's building a
autonomous humanoid robot yeah that's
basically like a robot slave that can
lift and carry and do tasks here it is
oh this is the presentations away let me
build up to this
he's saying it will be out next year
next year ela is this thing ready dan we
ready for this bit yeah it's in uh
ian'll play it
so here's the specs
pretty exciting stuff humanoid robot can
carry 45 pounds
five eight
125 pounds interesting you can dead lift
okay let's take this thing in the gym
can spot me
can go up to five miles per hour in
similar stats to me
built world built by humans for humans
friendly you really gotta put friendly
like i'm getting a little suspicious of
elon like bro
the singularity already happened and
this guy's working to end humanity
bro you really gonna add a bullet point
this is friendly and i'm not supposed to
get suspicious
i don't know well anyway i don't think
we have much to worry about because
here's his progress so far on this
[Music]
robot if you're thinking that is a human
being in a jumpsuit
you would be
totally correct
you unveiled the robot at an event
and it's just a dude
so you might be asking what the [ __ ]
and you certainly wouldn't be alone in
that
that is literally just a dude
uh and this robot's supposed to be out
next year by the way what the [ __ ] like
yeah
yeah
thank you so
was he talking about the robot like
separate from this like in a serious way
or is it just this one kind of stunt
uh
he
do you mean like previous to this event
had he been talking i think they've like
hinted that they were thinking about
building robots their whole uh
premise is that you know they they build
lots of robots all the time in their uh
assembly line to build their cars so
it's no different to just build like a
humanoid robot
which seems like a stretch it seems
pretty different actually
especially considering this is the guy
who always complains about artificial
intelligence and how much it scares him
right lots of people have pointed out
that he's like always talking about how
ai is going to be the end of humanity
and then here he is making victory
you guys might be happy to know
that
we got a prototype for lava
we are going to project love's
consciousness into
the tesla robot
and we've got a sneak peek for you guys
here
and now
what the hell
two h3 podcasts from elon
teslabot
doesn't really look like legit packaging
jesus
christ
hey guys
what love what the hell is this dude
yeah i got a little upgrade what do you
guys
think it looks like uh american horror
story this is the new love thought
love you're freaking me out a little bit
i don't know if i like this
what do you mean what's wrong
it's kind of scary looking it's
unsettling way better than the other
lovebots
are you doing those dance moves are
those your moves
yep
all me
this is kind of disturbing dude can you
make him stop doing those dances jesus
christ love stop it stop it dude
just come here go do some go work yeah
don't don't don't run away go do some
work you look like a spider dude stand
still yeah come let me take a look at
you
hey guys whoa this is the new bot holy
[ __ ] what is this what the hell it's a
new tesla robot
i can't believe it actually works
love
these american ships are pretty good
after all
what are you talking about this is a
robot it doesn't ingest food
hey hey hey come on
get off of my feet dude i'm just
thinking something all over me dude
you're making a mess get this ticket
dude what are you doing this is
disgusting man yo thank you for life
yeah
get the fika out of here get the fika
out of here get the fika out come on
guys what's
you
the
issue
mess what do you do
oh i'm trying to eat some fake yeah bro
[ __ ]
you know where you know okay get in this
one jesus what what is your problem dude
[ __ ] you i don't like your attitude [ __ ]
you we have a real problem if you'll
start [ __ ] around turn off the water
what are you [ __ ] up to i'm going to
turn off the jesus
i'm turning off the wi-fi you don't
settle down [ __ ] off [ __ ] you love [ __ ]
you
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out yeah
just settle down just settle into your
spot
guys do you have some more fiki or no
[ __ ] off you've had enough fika there's
a [ __ ] freaking mess all over the
place just give me the feet i'll shoot
you yo if you don't [ __ ] settle down
i'm gonna [ __ ] stop that [ __ ] i'm
gonna get the super soaker dude i'll be
destroying the office i'm going to go do
you guys next i'm going to destroy you
you want the super soaker oh bro
zack jack zach just chill just chill
you can't beat it
listen
love i gotta go to the bathroom bro this
seems kind of dumb
yeah it's just it's just me what the
[ __ ]
that's what elon did i was trying to
save money because the new love bots
like fourth grand four grand i mean what
the [ __ ] you love
me you were in on this love i was role
playing i was a good idea what do you
mean saving some money but anyway i'm
over it i'm gonna go to the bathroom
no
yeah you're on your own buddy there's
chips everywhere
[Music]
wow
what a sweater for boating
ending
love having fika with a i m what does it
mean
yeah great job love on
selling that
thank you thank you
fantastic thank you for life
okay so so we have still we've got the
create challenge which i definitely want
to get to and of course we have mr
verified
oh we got the birthday songs how long
have we gone i have a lot left i want to
do
uh an hour and 50 minutes i'm gonna need
a burrito if i'm gonna continue another
no
oh i just took a bite okay deep throated
i'll grab i'm gonna go to the bathroom
thank you thank you olivia you're a real
one
so ian i'm gonna go to the bathroom you
want to do the um dawn day debrief
do you want do you want today do you
want to take the lead on that as i step
away for a moment uh i gotta pee as well
are you serious or is that a sound no
like actually
okay go pee and i'll wait jesus christ
you can't can you yeah
i was waiting for a good kid has a grape
sized bladder
yes i'll say you have to pee right now
really bad thank you joe
i'm not taking a pause to pee
i just paid in my basement
hahaha i peed in my basement
we have a lot of crate challenges
we got birthday songs
how you feeling what are we doing this
weekend
come here sweetie what are we doing
we have no plans currently look at this
sweet boy we love him so much
hey real quick i feel obligated to read
this off we have a
250 pound british pound donation and you
know what the message is it just says
for donna
whoa
and then the same person donated another
90 pounds and said when will ela be on
cameo
i don't think hila's got time to be on
cameo i'm afraid i don't think i can do
it
thank you guys thank you so much for the
donation i'll say for donna
okay you want me to give that to mom i
gotta pay taxes first [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
it's friday [ __ ] baby
take youtube's cut
[ __ ] baby now
this is sweet
oh one other
piece of breaking news once again
another 20 donation i have a confession
i paid all the paid actors who have
confessed on the stream i orchestrated
this astro turkey against ab
i am the dk bongo girl
[Music]
aka bongo girl has been sabotaging you
baby
hey amy what's the chance that you you
expressed uh concern
that the dk bongo girl would see
is there any possibility of that
happening do you do are you like friends
with her on facebook what's the story
there
uh no i don't think i'm friends
with her anywhere i mean
i do know a friend of hers a mutual
friend that watches well did watch
frenemies so that's the only connection
i could think of because i did is there
any way we could get her on the show to
talk about it
because i'm curious i love her every
telling of it that would be really
interesting
would you be down for that yeah i don't
mind
well
i'm super
good
let's make that happen i mean that's
exciting ab are you willing to release
her name to me so i can find her
well hmm might be hard in my hometown a
lot of the girls have the same name well
you have a friend of a friend just reach
out to your friend yeah
yeah i mean tell her the
clip
and be like we need
we need this we need you all right ian
you back
okay donde dondo
how do i control the link all right i'll
be right back this is all in now cool
well
i mean
you need a minute
well the the footage is on nathan's
computer right oh here all all here just
i'll drive
[Music]
so yeah from gonda you know the album
says what
third third time third time listening
party yeah yeah
it was last night i don't know he did
some controversial stuff you know big
shocker
gets old it's kind of old but
the real kicker is that uh
dunkey
he um
he
said he got an early copy a few weeks
ago yeah and he played some of the songs
that he allegedly had and so we got a
clip of one of them if we want to play
that
we're doing track four golden money
featuring pitbull here we go running it
back
[Music]
twitch.tv user notice
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
we're doing track four golden money
featuring pitbull so that was it so he
played that that was i think like two
and a half weeks ago three weeks ago and
so then he connie had his third
listening party last night
and something interesting happened i
think we have the clip
uh on that tweet if you've got it dan
yep
okay
apparently it's a song from some like
german yeah cartoon it's actually in
here you want me to pull up the original
yeah yeah okay
so you guys think he saw the donkey i
mean it seems i mean what other
explanation is this wow
maybe he's a dunky fan
here's the original
i'm the globglogabgalab okay i love boss
and this basement is a true treasure
trove
what is this
these are some deep cuts oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
where did donkey find this
wow
were these existing like memes or did
donkey make
his like version of the song
for good it kind of sounded a little
different i don't know
i think it was existing for the
he got the actual hard drive
cam says it was an existing meme okay
and it's kind of a good song
you ain't got the answer swing
[Laughter]
the glow glob
so he
i mean did you are you following them
that's pretty crazy
how donkey predicted it
was you
he must have seen the donkey
so you explained how
dunkey predicted it
yeah
you're saying predict but i mean we
think that kanye saw it and just
embraced the meme yeah right
i totally agree yeah
that's wild
it's unbelievable
can you at least take lulu bites so you
can still talk in between
it's a little left
it's ian's supposed to be leading the
segment
it didn't save us
let's save us ian
no this is kind of nice
i think you should chew a little cluster
[Laughter]
i got something from cam okay
and you talk about how
marilyn manson was there
no not uh we haven't met i'm not seeing
no not just him look in the bottom left
oh
oh
yeah i remember that i didn't know you
guys were out there
below maryland
who is
here like what is going on so marilyn
manson
it's marilyn manson and the baby the
baby yeah top left i think a couple of
cool guys it's like the avengers of
being cancelled
yeah it's not not great okay
the baby said something very offensive
focus
everyone's so focused on the the baby
part but it's like marilyn manson aaron
is like harvey weinstein level predator
who's about to go to jail
yeah he's like four
maybe more uh sexual assault cases
pending against him right now
oh essay sorry
he also has a you know other a cases too
i mean really notoriously spits on
people and he gets
yeah he was being sued for that
well kanye definitely knows how to pick
the
the cool kids
i'm trying to finish up here okay i'm
done so
i guess what he's trying to do is some
kind of like we're all canceled in this
house but i don't know why is he
i'm assuming why else would they be
there
i'm assuming that's some good statement
well i mean the baby is a rapper
who's doing a feature on it right that
one at least makes sense but i don't
think marilyn is involved in the
production i heard he might
so the song um
originally had jay-z on it and then last
night he took jay-z off put the baby on
and then apparently
marilyn was on it too at one point and
then he wasn't i don't know he's moving
things around so much but
i would not want to be on that stage
next jay-z not being there could be also
that jay-z pulled out oh for
sure but like did i see people say that
he also moved out um kid cody
yeah he took him off too
is that do you think that will cause
rifts with the friendship or they're
just cool with it i don't well who knows
he's like man i got six more concerts
before i'm releasing this thing i'll
just get you on the next one yeah
we have plenty of room for you
what's weird is um
you know marilyn manson always had this
shtick where it's like i look creepy but
i'm actually a super nice guy that's
what i always thought right like there
was interviews of him he's super well
spoken
he's super intelligent and articulate
but then no it turns out he's actually a
literal r-wordist and he like spits on
people and is actually just a disgusting
freak
so
yeah that's not a good look here for
kanye
i mean yeah why didn't he just bring out
harvey weinstein woody allen get the
whole crew together i think the uh the
um ted bundy interlude on part four's
on fire
yeah it's super super like what is wrong
with them bro are people angry about
this ian in the fandom yeah
yeah people aren't stoked on it
but he got the headlines but nobody
cares ultimately i mean right nobody's
gonna it's not gonna affect him at all
and this is the same week he uh docks
drake as well what the hell was that
story ian you want to take a lead on
that no i saw the picture he put out a
picture of google maps but did he really
show the address because it just had
like some blue lines on it no yeah it
was it was in your apple map or your
when you take photos on an iphone it
shows you where it was taken and so you
can see the crossroads and the houses
are so big there that you definitely
know it's like obviously drake has
security you can't just roll everyone
knows where he lives but i google
drake's address
and it shows up first thing
still worth to do that it is super
creepy and weird but
dude i don't know i'm out on kanye i
don't know how people can forgive this
guy so many times ian
like the dude is
done so many horrific things
yeah it's just uh the spectacle at this
point and kanye plays into it you know
and he's not even making music that's
the thing he's like he's like
he's at the point where it's like
whether you like the music or not i'm
just going to get you talking
whether it's good or bad i'm getting to
get you talking about me
all right did you guys did you see the
donda stem player
for like 200 bucks
he'll send you like a little machine
that has supposedly the files for donda
and like you can mix it how you want
baby bought one
i bought one because i thought i could
flip it but when ian being a
follower of kanye wasn't interested in
i'm like oh [ __ ] i emailed them like
thank you my money back
really out here flipping [ __ ] amy god
yeah such a hustler yo triller my thing
is flipped
i i've got some milf token for you oh
nice i think you can flip those all
right let's do some great challenge
before we review these great challenge
videos that are the best
remember after this we are going to be
going to the mr verified results
so get your votes in people link is in
the description
have you seen these hilo
no
i see some pop up on my feeds here and
there but so basically you taking these
like
crates that you see at grocery stores
stacking them and try to walk across it
why the thing is
bro it's super entertaining to watch
because
when you fall you fall so hard
you can't grab anything you try to grab
the crates fall all goofy and bro the
falls are absolutely brutal that you see
on this i guess i should say don't try
this at home yeah uh do not do this at
home it's very dangerous i wouldn't do
it i would encourage anyone zack wanted
to do it and i was like hell no i don't
want you to get hurt i would have done
it i believe you but i don't want you to
do it i would have done it i would have
succeeded
i 100 i'm sure you would have not
succeeded
the whole course is just like a little
hop for zach though
anyway here
this is like my whole twitter feed my
whole
feed instagram i mean it's awesome i
love watching it
i don't you don't i love it
it's just the most brutal falls oh my
god
they're all so brutal
that was pretty good man that was like a
good neck break fall like look at this
boom yeah i don't like watching that
i looked at kelsey grammer of course the
first crate uh
challenge victim
yeah there's huge crowds people got
really into it like there's like i saw
one dude being like we're doing the
crate olympics come over to my house
we're giving away them five thousand
dollars
it's all spectacle man
great challenge getting out of hand oh
for sure
i want to know where people getting all
these crates
i wouldn't know where to get these
crates from just ripping off the grocery
store yeah you could probably ask them
for it no any yeah anything that has
like shipments with produce like there's
as far as gas stations probably
primarily gas stations and party stores
there's got to be a crate shortage right
now for sure yeah right now yeah go on
ebay tell me if it costs for a crate i
bet it's scarce jacked up uh i am going
i just went to home depot to check the
price gotta be and
yeah the first
uh yeah out of stock out of stock view
similar stock
of you similar stock out of stock out of
stock yep
great
it's a great rush let's see if it's on
amazon's looking on amazon
oh they got plenty on amazon they got
yeah they got it this is america they
got you covered up we got you covered on
ebay
don't miss it oh man
on concrete too like bro look at that oh
why because it you just
why would you do that i'll tell you guys
at the top is where you gotta do your
move once you make it to the top that's
where you do your little your little
spice you mix it up there so he was
trying to do a hop over the rest of it
and it [ __ ] up yeah it's so it's so
good because it's
you think that
it's stable because they're together but
it's not you're just on a big ass wobbly
thing of crates
and it's just so out of hand yeah that's
like damage bro that's like really i
love how no one goes towards him
everyone runs away from him it's awesome
it's like is he hurt
let's run
oh here we go crate challenge for one
thousand dollars let's [ __ ] go right
now
i have seen people succeed though elo
it's not like nobody um
in the hood for a thousand
oh dude and that one looks taller than
usual man
robert
so this guy just set up crates and it's
just like yo do this for it that way
that guy was close that looked very
painful i wanted to go again
damn
yeah
i mean it's great content if you just
want to set up some crates in a park
which don't do that do not do that we
don't ever do this under any condition
for any reason
that being said
here here's someone completing the
challenge ela
so
you might enjoy this
hey everybody saying go south go let's
go east
come on man and i'ma buy you a zombie
hey see
the thrill the joy the victory
we love it
old dude eats [ __ ] this one's called
is he on a scooter
i just saw a chat did you all see the
girl with heels she nailed it i'm gonna
find out real quick
is
no hands oh gee
he got it he got it he got it get over
it
he's pretty high yeah
yeah you already put your hands down
he's smoking too at the same time by the
way oh [ __ ] oh my god that guy is way
too old to be taking a spill like that
man
i mean that's just an absolutely brutal
fall
and that's why we love the crate
challenge folks
this challenge getting out of hand this
challenge getting oodahan ela tell me if
this one's udahand or not
that is serious damage dad
this is
great
love it
uh when oh here's the lady who does it
in heels
successfully
so
not all else
got some dubs in here actually the two
people we've seen victorious were both
women interesting
and high heels no less what on earth
i wonder if that helps her balance you
know in a
[Music]
but there's holes all over the crate
though so no there can't be a hole in
the top that'd be impossible right i
think the whole thing has holes most of
them usually do it it does look like
these are solid dude there's no way
there's holes on the top yeah
it makes some noise
she said be quiet
quite on set for her
this is crazy impressive yeah it looks
crazy
[Music]
there you go the crate
there is your mrs verified forget you
guys
here's one why is this one in yellow
should i be scared of this no this one's
my favorite oh this is your favorite
this guy's just so smooth okay we got a
smoothness
[Laughter]
[Music]
nailed it jesus
mr verified
damn there's a lot of them get the man
some henny
this one's my favorite
this one is pretty good
[Music]
this is the real life he needs some milk
[Music]
i think it's shaking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're not going to put any in his
mouth is it are they
dude he's like
were they saying get him some honey yeah
[Laughter]
aiden ross did it apparently in a [ __ ]
why not let's watch that one too
this is the last one so
yeah those are wide ones so some people
try to cheat
they try to lie this they try to do the
super wide one sideways so it looks
legit but it's way more stable
but he's still like [ __ ] yeah
you got it
oh
man that is such a brutal fall
get him some honey
so
great fall oh okay so miss get your
votes in guys mr verified
this is it this is the last chance maybe
we should do the birthday songs first i
love these
that's
up to you
get your votes in we're almost done how
many votes we got love on verified mr
verified
let me check it out one second
get him in guys get him in we got those
are not here regulation crates
uh real quick well he's looking that up
uh 50
super chat my fiance and i met and
bonded over our mutual love of the show
and at the start of the summer we got
engaged
we want white claw gabe to officiate our
wedding yeah we could probably book that
on camera will you all attend
yeah if you want like claw uh his cameo
is the best way to reach him yeah reach
him on camera you can get a premium
camera [ __ ] it's friday you can get my
mom to do it too
congratulations
all right our final segment before mr
verified results i've discovered
something a long time ago on the
internet
if you go on
google images or now specifically
youtube and you have a friend's birthday
let's say you know whatever their name
is and you type happy birthday whatever
there's always the weirdest and most
interesting results
interesting so we did
happy birthday for each member of the
crew
and each result was so different and so
interesting
um
it's a lot of fun
happy birthday zach was our first one so
here so here you go happy birthday zach
this one was specifically made for you
buddy
and if you if you have a friend named
zach and you just send this to him
that's such a great
surprise
like oh my god
if
i think they all
[Music]
are laughing at you back yeah okay
happy birthday
wow that was improvised for sure
absolutely yeah i'm not going to throw
in the last name
yeah no no no no let's keep it generic
but he knows so happy birthday zach
buddy thank you very much personally
powerful a powerful birthday message for
that incredibly i thought that was the
joker behind him there's a poster on the
wall i thought was the joker tripped me
out glad it's not that's my own i can't
tell honestly
what do you mean that's your uncle what
do you mean the guy yeah yeah it's my
uncle no right yeah
happy birthday ian
on the big
birthday surprise ian
so this one has 47 000 views huh buddy
there was only 300 on the zach one
[Music]
put your hands together
for
the
this one's called epic happy birthday so
you have like content farms where they
just put in the game
but it's still a lot of work
[Music]
you know actually i think this is going
to be on donda
next one
are you a little bit jealous that he
actually took donkey's advice because i
know you were trying to reach out to him
for a long time back during your big
fandom phases and we always had
conspiracy theories about if kanye was
listening to you or not but i feel like
he really did senpai noticed donkey or
does that make you jealous at all
no actually the first donkey video i
ever saw was
this he did this uh
review of a kanye video game called
kanye quest that was posted on the fan
site that's how i found dunkey the first
time oh no way he's been doing kanye's
stuff for a while oh
[Music]
didn't know that i know donkey's like a
hip-hop head i didn't know he was a
company boy though
he's got to feel pretty good from that
we should get him a call we should get
him on the phone and ask him yeah
well that uh that birthday song was a
jam
you're very welcome happy birthday
next up abdullah
happy birthday ab abdullah let's see
what we got for you
yo 250 000 bro wow
i guess there's a lot of abdullah in the
world
abdullah sorry abdullah but yeah no it's
it's yeah pretty common name overseas
did you get a capri sun yeah what the
[ __ ] where'd that come from i found the
fridge the foot what about all of us
yeah you didn't bring enough capri suns
for the class
you guys remember the time you guys all
had a burrito and i didn't
but i got like a pre-sign
i i'm like i'm sorry i don't remember
that it's not your i'm with you i don't
have a burrito either but that's just
not a choice i had two burritos
taking the food right out of our mouth
there's still some left if you guys want
all right abdullah thank you
let's go
[Music]
is there verbal or is it if this is it
dude
[Music]
no they just say abdullah yeah
fantastic this is
how do you feel ab
[Music]
oh
this kicked up a notch this is huge man
this is major
you think it's computer generated
that sounds like a real person
abdullah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching
so is bmw another
[Applause]
like arabic name because i saw bmw i've
never heard that name before
where here be maul
wait i'm trying to click it who's [ __ ]
bmall this one's rare it only has 3000
views
this is a rare birthday i never heard
this name in my whole life
you don't know this name
i've never heard of that here let's see
how he says it
[Music]
[Music]
who's culture now
joe biden wake up
so moving on to dan
oh yeah
you excited dan look at this one
forty thousand views oh wow happy
birthday dan
[Music]
i travel for miles to put a smile on
your face this guy's definitely a pedo
possible alternative explanation happy
birthday
you're cool
oh
my home is mars this guy's the same
taste of minutes james charles
did you see it do you see what just
happened let me go back no
damn
[Laughter]
[Applause]
such [ __ ] that's awesome i wonder
how many that's there that's fraud it's
right here's whoosh from mars
oh yeah he has birthday look at all of
them get the [ __ ]
out of here you wow uh van harry miley
taylor zachary zach william well
this is awesome look at this [ __ ] jesus
they have zachary anzac that's it they
didn't wait there's actually not really
that many they could have done a lot
more yeah i think i know i think this is
a comedian i i think his name is mike
mitchell
he looks super familiar
i doubt he was involved in the creation
of this
someone's trying to rack it in whoosh
from mars
it does kind of look like
what there's wait a minute there's a lot
of mike mitchells
well happy birthday dan thank you
i feel came all the way from mars a
little ripped off
of course i feel the need to say i don't
think he's a p word that's a horrible
thing to say about someone i was just
kidding
he's a real person yadda yadda whatever
whatever i mean you know whatever
let me get a taste
of that yeah there's another
third one let me get a taste
[Music]
all right this one's for me happy
birthday ethan everyone get it hyped
let's go
oh yeah
[Music]
give me pizza
right
70 000 ethan's become quite a popular
name yeah
man when i was like do you really
deserve the cat content though yeah true
previous statements no i don't wanna do
that
you know when i was a kid i was the only
ethan i ever knew growing up until i was
like
in college and then everyone started
recalling ethan
so
here this guy's been cranking them out
aren't these channels so interesting
yeah like what yeah it's just phillip
miles mom oliver melvin nicole patrick
pedro mark madison i mean look at this
yeah they're just
farming views
i mean is it worth the effort the views
aren't that nice you know what i mean
like you just make a video once and then
you change the name
i'm assuming there's got to be some some
computer
it's all automated or something yeah but
like if you're in india or some really
low or like people don't make that much
money then if you're making like a
thousand dollars a month then all of a
sudden like that's a really good living
that's a good point and if you just need
some
you just need some kind of system
a good amount of them have
fifteen twenty here let's sort by
probably is it organized is it
alphabetized yeah did they upload from z
up it looks like it that's why it was a
computer for sure
so then if they're like oh shoot i
forgot nathan
like
you gotta start over done right
so let's go so josh by the way coming in
number one with three hundred thousand
views mom dad crushing it
for more than mom and dad how many
josh's are there
josh's questions surprising right sarah
chloe jessica chris these are all top
names guys lily's a top name
wow
wow this is the first time for me
in the epic happy birthdays universe wow
that's real fascinating though i find
this whole thing 160 000 subscribers to
that channel too yeah they want every
upload
notifications on so ela
you even got one
which in america you know in israel's
common name but not here in america boy
hmm interesting let's see what we got
yeah
would you get down
we're going to be late for highland
spurs
i hope there will be cheese at
highland's birthday party
by far the most rare
[Music]
but like if i sent this to you on your
birthday you'd be pretty surprised yeah
you're like oh [ __ ]
this is from what is free on my birthday
very funny it says in parentheses
now this one
these guys been hard at work man unless
you most popular
45 000
struggling yeah not really worth it
yeah but i have a feeling these guys
have a lot of videos
oh not that much
they gave up
uh
sam has copyrighted music we'll have to
be careful here
oh my goodness this looks high effort
sam
happy birthday
breaking news what the kevin kneeling
yep the [ __ ]
[Music]
hello and thanks for joining us i'm
kevin nealen
our top story tonight it appears that
happy birthday wishes are in order
[Music]
yes i have confirmation
we're talking about you sam oh
what
how'd they get
i don't is this all ai generated i don't
know if that wait hold on that i'm
confused now um
let me sort okay so here's kevin
now let's see if he says it for kevin
because that sounded like his voice
seems
yes i have confirmation
we're talking about you kevin
bro what is going on
ai yeah yeah i don't know if that's
really kevin talking if you listen
closely yeah
are you serious turn it up for me
you kevin that sounds like his voice i
don't know what you guys are saying
information listening we're talking
about you kevin
right it can be like one of those jay-z
i don't hear it
the whole video is i generated not only
the name yeah that's what i was saying
i don't know if this is
yes i have confirmation
we're talking about you kevin
what
but that's 14 views man
wait it was uploaded like last week
dude what this channel is so freaky
dude this is the weirdest channel that's
what i'm saying man you go people are
saying
not that difficult to do there's
tutorials online yeah i i think it's uh
yeah it's very crazy okay well here's
william shatner now i'm curious here's
william shatner wishing lynn i've done a
lot of things in my career
but this takes the cake this is so cool
you lynn he's got toyota's all about you
what's with his eye
you were born today
[Music]
yeah
okay
i think that this i remember that this
was an old commercial with william
shatner so i think they take existing
footage here's from the queen now i'm
just really fascinated with their
process
but on the bbc i haven't always been i
mean
this was a big story this video grateful
to the opportunity to say whatever i
like
without anyone putting words in my mouth
oh that's that's [ __ ] up
thank you
a special someone it seems is what oh
you see this is dog food
kevin gilson one
really
lady calvin kneeling one was so legit
yeah this channel is freaky and weird
yeah
let's get out of here
like i'm on the dark web
we've got a cam of course cam
common i'm sure there's no shortage of
happy birthday cams
say happy birthday
come on you can do it it's kemp's
birthday
[Music]
[Laughter]
and of course finally olivia
happy birthday oh we got an alien
oh yeah
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so if you guys have a friend or a
loved one or a parent or whoever
child's birthday
search it on youtube something fantastic
out there and each one of these was so
different and unique um just like the
individuals they are they're all right
and unique and beautiful
well guys
there's nothing left to do
get to the results of mr verified 2021.
love can you send me the results please
yes sir should i send the discord okay
this is it let's get some music going
zach let's get the let's get the the
moment right
guys you if you got haven't got your
vote in
you have about one minute
where did you put the link club
i'm thinking i should dm you privately
so they don't see it
did you send me
here
apparently
well just just i mean it's fine if they
they're not going to click it
they're asking where was the love happy
birthday song oh yeah love where's love
happy birthday song
oh olivia's got it i'm sorry love
hey hold on
all of them are happy birthday my love
wait don't oh don't
delete that love
i thought you were going to show it to
me i thought it was a link
here oh it's my love yeah
it's a tough one
[Music]
my love i mean that doesn't really work
does it i'm sorry love
so wait send me i thought it was gonna
be a link or something okay so dm me i
mean i didn't get it anywhere
yeah i can't dm i'll send this on
whatsapp
on whatsapp okay i'll just use my yeah i
can't dm me on discord okay all right i
have the results the music please zach
drum roll
this is interesting
this is really interesting
can i hear a drumroll
i don't want you i mean
thank you guys thank you
thank you guys
wow the results are surprising
yeah they are shocking
a little bit unexpected
[Music]
i'm going to start from the bottom up
and fourth place with 18
of the total vote by the way we have 51
562 votes cast
that's a lot
in last place with 18
nine thousand
thirty six votes
we have
dan oh
your wish was granted then
your wish was granted
now that surprised me i expected you to
be higher up i'm not gonna lie okay but
you did still get 18 so it wasn't like a
blow up
so dan is in last place
up next
[Music]
the crew member
who got third
with ten thousand
nine hundred and thirty eight votes
twenty one percent
third place
we have
a b
third place
how do you feel about that you know the
bongo was such a great entry i wasn't
sure where to place you
i i expected to be third or fourth so
now you beat dan out by a good thousand
votes so
i'm okay with that
dan is the unsung hero so i'm okay being
so now it comes down to zach
[Music]
and ian
how are you guys feeling this is a big
moment my heart's racing
are you happy to be in the top two zack
i am and i'm glad i'm with you zach's a
killer he crushed it so
ian how are you feeling are you are you
nervous are you excited
a little bloated but that's
[Music]
at this point i'll just announce the
winner yeah i guess so
the winner
of mr verified
2012
with a whopping 36
wow
as opposed to second place with 25
a whopping 18
650
points
[Laughter]
a margin of
4 000 vote difference
the winner
by unanimous consent
is
ian
mr verified
2021 play this song zach
play with your voice with your singing
come come come come come
please join us ian with your pants
falling
[Music]
do you have a microphone
grab your mic there
mr verified
he is glorious
[Music]
we have uh
ian happy for you i'm gonna let you
finish but zach had one of the best
performances of all
let's bring out the crown and the sash
you
[Music]
very
[Applause]
[Music]
uh well sam we're gonna have a
conversation later
no uh zach was incredible he was you
know
i i would pull another an adele right
now and give this to zach but frankly i
don't want to but i would
and you're the man i love you no you're
great and a b crushed he's the bongo
legend and
dan is
you got a last word he deserved i got
what i wanted you want to what you got
psychology you got my brain a little bit
yeah maybe i should vote for dan
right from the beginning i thought he
had it but uh today you win not only an
email from me
that email from you
but also we're going to be working with
a freelance writer to write an article
about your victory so that we can
plead a legitimate case for verification
how does that make you feel good that's
really wonderful how many paragraphs we
talk in the email uh 500 words the email
oh oh i thought even the article
oh i don't know a paragraph few
sentences
i mean i'll write what i feel i need to
and we'll i'll show the email i've seen
anything in the emails it's probably
like two sentences
oh come on i write good email okay okay
but what more do you need to say three
sentences
i'll make the best possible case got it
okay well thank you thank you guys for
buying i appreciate that also uh
yes
it's in the mail but we also got you a
hundred dollar gift uh card to sharky
i've done enough [ __ ] on this show
i can't go back to the bathroom well
thank you guys wow congratulations
congratulations what uh
what a day folks what a show
ian he is mr verified
mr verified
look at him go
oh look at him he can sing he can dance
make sure you guys get a good look at
that crown
[Music]
and let's enjoy zach's song actually
[Music]
it is a great crowd okay
[Applause]
because he
is
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you everybody
it's friday
there's no work no school no school
it's good vibes only that's right
there's no [ __ ] work
[Applause]
sing us out zach sing us out bad song we
lost some zach yep
sing us out buddy
go to slate and just sing us out all
right that's it thanks for watching
everybody song going well that was the
end of the song okay let's start it over
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at his smile isn't he great
mr verified
[Music]
an email sent to instagram to give
the blue check the mark
that makes you see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so look at the beauty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you